- Hey guys.
How's it going?
Today we are unboxing
something super exciting
and it is one of my most
favorite things to test out.
This is the new Mophie XXL USB-C charger.
What's extremely exciting about this one
is that its USB-C and there's enough power
in here to charge a MacBook.
A MacBook that of course
charges with USB-C.
So we're gonna test that
out, see if it works.
But first, we have to do the unboxing.
I can't wait to try this out.
So, let's open it up.
Take a look.
We've got some things,
the amount of extra battery you'll receive
depends on a variety of factors
that are different for every user.
That is very, very true.
Aaaahhhh.
Look at this guys.
Unfortunately, you can't feel
this because it's a video.
But it is way different
than any of the other
Mophie's that I've had because
it feels like a, I don't
even know what to explain.
It's kind of like a felt,
but it's like a weird feel.
(sniff)
Doesn't have a smell.
It's interesting because
most of the other Mophie's
that I have, I've never
felt one that feels like
its got a little bit of like,
it feels like a sweatshirt
around it, but its completely
covered in this fabric
which is actually kind of nice
because this is something
that you're going to
be using most likely on
your desk with your MacBook.
So, it's something that
won't slide around.
Whereas some of the other Mophies,
I mean, I guess they don't
really slide around either.
But this slides around
way less than the others.
So these are a few of my
other favorite Mophies.
This one has pretty much gotten me by
for the past couple of years.
This is the Mophie 8X charger.
This one is 15,000 milliamps
and this new one is, which is interesting,
because when I first read
the pre-release of this,
it was like 21,000 I think.
But now it looks like
its clocked at 19,500.
There's a little sticker over top of it.
So perhaps this changed in later testings.
At that rate, that'll give you 14+ hours
on your MacBook, 20 hours on iPad Air 2,
and 100 hours on your iPhone.
Something else to note is, obviously
if your phone or your MacBook is off,
it's going to charge
at a much faster rate.
So if you are desperate,
either shut your phone off,
put it in airplane mode,
but do shut your MacBook
off if you are desperate
for a fast charge.
It looks like we've got two
bars already on this guy.
Two different ports here.
We've got our USB-C and our regular USB
which we're most familiar with.
And here is the fabric finish.
I wish that you could
touch it, but you can't.
There's a little button to show how
much we're charged.
So I have a few other
comparison Mophies here.
This is another one of their USB ones
which I've also been using quite a lot.
So we have 10,000, 15,000, 3,020.
I really like this line
of the power stations
because they have a built-in USB cable.
So we've got this little thing pops off
so it gives you a
USB-micro and this little
converter, converts to lightning.
And then it just goes right in like this.
Charges through USB-micro,
the only downfall of
some of the smaller ones
is they don't have another USB port.
So you basically have to charge it
using the built-in cable.
This one, I'm still in love with.
Even though it's the size of an iPad Mini.
I just like that it's super flat
so a lot of the backpacks that I have,
I can just kinda slide this nicely in
and fit a lot of things around it.
But all things considered,
this one is, I mean, it is much bigger,
it's also a lot thicker.
It's got a premium fabric wrap.
That's what they're calling it.
Anything else I should know?
(mumbling)
Guess not.
This is retailing for $150,
which is about the same price as this one.
Lets see what else is inside this box.
We've got a USB-C to USB-C.
Our basic USB to a basic USB-C.
I think that's all we've got in here.
But now for the real test.
Will this little Mophie charge my MacBook?
Plug it in here to our USB-C.
Then plug it in here.
Listen for it.
(beep)
Do you know what that sound is?
That sound means, oh baby, we're charging.
And I'm happy about it.
I feel like this is
going to be a great thing
for planes, for traveling, in the car.
One of the things that
I'm going to be curious is
to see how much a full battery of this
will actually charge my MacBook.
So I will try that out
and give you maybe guys
an update on Twitter,
or Instagram, or wherever
it is that you follow me.
That that information may
be easy to get across.
Or maybe even in a vlog.
Who knows?
This thing is pretty cool and
I'm super excited about it.
I'm not sure how I feel about the fabric.
It's very different than
all of the previous models.
But what I will say, is it
looks really, really good.
Like, look how nice this looks.
It's incredible.
Great work Mophie. Let me
know what you guys think.
What battery chargers do you
use for your external devices?
I would love to know.
And let me know how many milliamps it is.
And if you're not sure where to find that,
most of them just say on the back
where the small, little,
tiny, fine text is.
I'll see you guys on my next video.
Bye.
(upbeat music)